[Musik]
und ja ich bin derzeit irgendwie mehr
sonnenbrand als mensch remy web chat
oder in folge hatte wahrscheinlich
mitbekommen dass ich die letzten drei
tage in westafrika war
ja kann man immer machen auf jeden fall
habe ich mir halt nicht bösen bei
gedacht und bin einfach am strand werben
das wetter war bewaffnet waren 20 grad
ich komme wieder ins hotel
den todes sonnenbrand weil der uv-index
tor zu hoch als dass meine augen tränen
die ganze zeit zurück geflogen mit
meiner haut hält sich gerade und nicht
mal guckt euch das mal anders ich bin
das ist dass ich will mehr rot als dass
ich irgendwas anderes meinem gesicht
habe ich habe schon sehr viele
nachrichten bekommen natürlich aus wie
eine tomate und wenn man mich pürieren
würde wäre ich tomatensaft er danke für
die netten aufmunternden worte
aber wir kommen auch mal endlich zum
thema des heutigen video gesagt habt ihr
zahlreich getan deswegen starten wir
direkt mit der ersten videoeinblendungen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich will nicht wissen was da noch
passiert weil solche videos enden
eigentlich immer blöd
[Gelächter]
ich habe euch im letzten video gesagt
leute ich warte wie ich auf einwendungen
leute irgendwie einfachen salto machen
irgendwie was können krass klavierspiel
das was sich diesmal wirklich wieder on
mars bekomme einfach so was wie sie zu
ihrer verteidigung sagen heute als ich
die videos bei twitter durchgegangen
wenn die mir eingesendet wurden war
wirklich einige videos dar wo leute
wirklich alles gemacht oder klavier
spielen konnten aber die meisten davon
darf ja nicht verwenden weil da
irgendwelche copyright musik wie eminem
oder so drunter geführt wurde
aber ich habe noch eine andere frage in
bezug auf dieses video und verwahrung
liegt davon damit noch mal schnee im
hintergrund waren heute allein in köln
22 grad mit kurzer hose und t shirt
rumgelaufen und verhaltet euch die
partie noch mal schnee wurde am nordpol
oder bekommen so unfassbar häufig diese
fragen gestellt ob bestimmte projekte
noch mal kommen können aber leute ich
lade wirklich täglich einfach dazu wo
ich gerade in genau dem moment lust
drauf habe das ist halt auch der grund
warum ich jetzt nicht für bestimmte
projekte auf meinem kanal bestimmte
tageszeiten blick habe den viel habe ich
leider mit minecraft damals begangen und
konnte mich daran halten aber wenn ihr
wirklich noch mal 54 wen wollt also das
ist ja diese serie wo beispielsweise so
was passiert ich habe die tür vergessen
[Musik]
irgendwie schafft ich will auch nicht
irgendwie geil wirken aber es ist halt
einfach die beste möglichkeit den
youtube zeigen ob man das oktobertief
bei 50.000 krank hohe zahl und wenn da
50.000 leute drauf bock haben dann lohnt
sich für mich das natürlich wieder
aufzunehmen
zu diesem video muss ich sagen dass dort
nicht noch geschrieben wurde hey you
can't hold a video zu sehen wo leute
wissen was können mein bruder hat extra
für dich klavierspielen gelernt dass
sich wird noch sagen wir schauen jetzt
mal das ganze video an
[Musik]
korrekte clayderman dass du extra für
mich dieses
diese
wir hören doch mal rein meine damen und
herren wirklich ich bin begeistert dass
du mit deinen hosenscheißer 23 jahre
oder so ich mein ich will ihn gar nicht
kritisieren die konten im alter noch
viel weniger irgendwie klappt wie ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich nie mehr das
klavier getroffen in dem alter ist aber
auf jeden fall danke für diesen track
ich führe die emotionen und ich bin ich
sind keine worte ich einfach wunderschön
gewesen
danke dir sehr von nadal hat durch ihr
okay immer wenn ich ein video hochladen
wo ich auf eure videos reagiere kommt
das krasse ist ja auch erst mal ein
bisschen real top 4
ich habe mitbekommen wie einige youtuber
abgemahnt wurden also abgemahnt heißt
dass sie irgendwie quasi mehr oder
weniger eine kleine anzeige bekommen
haben weil wegen der falsch gemacht
haben wurden mehrere youtuber abgemahnt
weil die werbung für ihre eigenen
produkte gemacht haben
deutschland hätte noch zu retten darf
doch wohl noch werbung für das machen
was man selber macht habe ich das ja
schon mal gesagt dass ich jetzt immer
werbevideo hinschreiben muss also das
was ich hier oben jetzt auch gerade
eingeblendet wenn ich irgendwas aus dem
interview
in mein video zeige oder diese anwendung
benutzer allerdings nicht wahrscheinlich
demnächst auch sogar der luca - shop.de
einblendung 4 millisekunden lang
irgendwie werbevideo einblenden und das
teil einfach farblich von dem rest des
videos trennen das heißt ihr habt jetzt
als aufgabe weil ich will nicht so blöd
er in die werbe video weiß auf schwarzem
schreiben oder sony hat jetzt die
aufgabe bei twitter unter dem hashtag
luca werbevideo irgendwelche
einblendungen einzufügen mit ihnen
irgendwelche video hochzuladen einfach
sagt jetzt kommt ein werbevideo für den
lukas ott und dann werde ich immer mal
ab und zu wöchentlich verschiedene
einblendungen von euch benutzen und ihr
könnt war sie teil meines video client
und ich glaube das ist so eine ganz gute
kombination aus ich bin rechtlich auf
der sicheren seite und bekomme keine
riesigen strafe und komme ich im knast
und andererseits interaktivität mit euch
aber wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
video was zum paket falsch mit dir
guckst du gerade ob dein handy wirklich
die kamera hat du wirst das umfallen ich
werde jetzt umfallen
wieso bin ich irgendwie umgefallen sein
ich sitze hier noch das macht keinen
sinn dazu sagt hallo
warum krieg ich sowas eine wendezeit
mädchen steht in ihrem wort und
gestenreich oder bei musik und tanz
dabei ich meine natürlich klar immer
wenn ich zb auf und spiegel und macht
ich verstehe einfach nicht weil diese
nächsten team hat mir jemand alter
schwede
ich sehe ich gerade in dem clip screen
normalerweise gucke ich mir ein damit
ich mehr in die linse konkurrenten
youtube sagen hey leute willkommen zu
meinem neuen video navigiert aber ich
habe keinen score points
vor
bin ich in roter bastard alltag
die nächsten video stand in dem tweet
dass man so richtig playstation spielt
wenn man
es spielt dann habe ich auch gehört die
akkulaufzeit der playstation auf
die akkulaufzeit der playstation
am strom angeschlossen lukas war wieder
allen gezeigt auf ganz youtube wie dumm
du eigentlich bist wenn ihr auch findet
lukas crafter mit einer von den dümmsten
youtube an ist dann lasst gern mal like
da das zeigen auf jeden fall dass ich
dumm bin
[Musik]
25 verpasste anrufe von mama op cool ich
meine kennt das locker so wenn du jeden
kollege anruft oder wurde eine freundin
ihr dann einfach so sieht ok der oder
die angerufene vielleicht eine stunde
zurück oder so das schreiben bei
rossmann a5 bei anrufen
ich hoffe mal zurück ein paar sekunden
später
bitte dich ran
ich glaube jetzt hat meine mama wieder
ein internetauftritt die aber nie geht
einfach nicht ran aber leute wir machen
weiter im programm cool dass ich
wirklich hier vom pc mir die video auf
wie automaten dann kommt auch noch die
einblendungen com haben war ist ja auch
schon so ein richtiger running gegner
also diesem format sagt ja das
eigentliche letzter zeit nicht wieder
aufgegriffen weil also wirklich steht
auch noch aus den tomatensaft also von
daher versteht man ja glaube ich ich
frag mich was eigentlich zu sagen hat
running gag coolste was hättest du
eigentlich zu tomatensaft zu sagen wo
morton coolsten auch wieder hammer was
hast du zu running gag zu sagen running
wie sitzt auf dem pferde kann ihm sagen
dass das sehr hoch springen ich weiß
nicht ob du warst kappe weil ich jetzt
wirklich geritten bin oder nie wirklich
was mit pferden zu tun hatte aber wenn
ein pferd einfach auf die dings klopft
auf den haltenden springt der stemmer
vollmann wird dass keine menschen machen
springmann mal mit
ja genauso wert beim
paul-luca in diesem video zeige ich dir
mal alle male apple-geräte huldiger
das ist also wirklich dass du alle deine
apple geräte zeigt
erst mal apple macbook pro läuft sich
ein apple macbook pro 30
ist
richtig geiles apple produkte mit einem
logo drauf manchmal was da noch so ein
angebot hat und hier und auf meinem
computer apple einkaufsliste wohl nur
pizza draufsteht welcher menschen in den
apple-shop bin ich eine einkaufsliste
auf der nur hitzer draufsteht
ja
das ist das beste apple produkt aller
zeiten
[Musik]
ohne spaß andere youtuber wenn die
aufwendige serie kriegen weggemacht
eigene seite wohl einen rückwärtssalto
vom ein-meter-brett machen oder aber
einer die welt rettet und weitere
heilmittel gegen findet der weg des
transports auf board welt man muss
allerdings sagen das ist wirklich sehr
sehr dramatisch dargestellt wurde also
probst an dich für cinematographie meine
lieben freunde hier heute zu einem neuen
video werde ich heute mal wieder mit dem
also wird video bestand fahrt wieder
rauskomme hingegen haut rein lief dann
war noch einmal ein partner dann er
hatte sich ein videoprojekt damit die
fresse gefallen da kam lukas ott
ja
sehr cool ich kann kein wayport fan aber
an nicht auf dem grund weil ihnen die
beigebracht habe oder weil irgendwie ist
einfach zu dumm bin vielleicht bin ich
auch zu dummen keine ahnung aber ich
finde so bei allem respekt also ich
glaube dass die spaß macht wenn man es
selber kann aber ich finde damit hab ich
auch wenn ich nach vorne und hinten bis
der fall denn schon lieber dann
skateboard normal oder longboard und
jetzt meine damen und herren kommen
wirklich eine einblendung als ich dafür
weil twitter gesehen habe mir dabei
angewendet wurde und dass auch dabei
stand so dass ich mir wirklich wieder
mit kann man wirklich über ein video
beendete eine mega live video
anwendungen mit gewesen
danke auf jeden fall dafür war so was
brauche ich immer besonders toll
das war's jetzt auch schon vom video
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat auf jeden fall meinen
daumen hoch da und wie gesagt kommt als
video mal wieder 5 4 nochmals für den
sonnenbrand aber ich bin halt einfach
wie gesagt da doch teneriffa kult meine
augen tränen die ganze zeit also die da
oben findet ihr ein smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr da draufsteht könnt ihr meinen
kanal ab und verpasst keine videos mehr
also macht das doch wer einmal da oben
findet auch meinen schock eingeblendet
wo in deutschland verkaufen können und
hier unten ist andere video verlinkt und
ist jetzt voll scheiße also klickt aber
nicht drauf da nicht drauf klicken
lieber nach draußen gehen spielen